el gobierno federal ha invocado la ley
de emergencias para completar la
capacidad provincial y territorial para
abordar los bloqueos y las ocupaciones
que se enrocase jones la ley entró en
vigor el lunes y con ella el gobierno
tendrá medidas temporales especiales
para garantizar la seguridad nacional
durante 30 días una decisión con la que
el primer ministro yo sin trudeau
buscará hacerle frente a los bloqueos y
protestas que se han presentado en el
país a raíz del llamado convoy de la
libertad
la ley de emergencia será usada para
fortalecer y apoyar a las fuerzas del
orden en todo nivel a lo largo del país
hitn que es para proteger la seguridad
de los canadienses proteger los empleos
y restaurar la confianza en nuestras
instituciones
la ley de emergencias de 1988 ha sido
pocas veces invocada en el país es la
segunda vez que se activa en tiempos de
paz fue el padre del mandatario pierre
elliott trudeau quien activó su versión
anterior en 1970 la aplicación de la
medida debe estar justificada por una
situación crítica y urgente que pone en
peligro las vidas la salud o la
seguridad de los canadienses y permite
incluso el traslado de los militares a
las calles del país las protestas ya
hicieron eco en la provincia de ontario
este fin de semana recibir
recomendaciones del doctor mor sobre un
plan para reabrir nuestra economía y
abandonar el sistema de pasaporte de
vacunas en ontario exit disfrutan de
edicions a pesar de que el puente
ambassador que comunica a canadá con su
vecino ya fue despejado los reclamos no
cesan en diferentes partes del país